ça sera bientôt le temps des bal des
finissants secondaire des balles et des
après bâle où l'alcool coule à flots
pour la cinquième année la sûreté du
québec qu'elle réalise une simulation
d'accident pour frappe évidemment
l'imagination des élèves et les
sensibiliser aux dangers de l'alcool et
de la drogue au volant ça sera un peu
partout au québec
philippe marcoux était à saint-hyacinthe
la vidéo qui ouvre les énormes entre
descendent que sais-je élèves qui se
préparent pour leur bal de finissants
connaissent bien mais ce à quoi les
organisateurs les sensibiliser se passe
en direct au centre de l'aréna l p
gaucher de saint-hyacinthe
nous on ne peut plus rien faire
transporté à l'hôpital pour dangereux
des fontes et montrer les primates on
voit que les collisions
mais le match peu après par encore
davantage par mi-temps dont et si ses
seins de réalisme troublant ne suffisent
pas la simulation était suivi du
témoignage très émouvant de sylvie roy
la mère de jade une adolescente sans
histoire morte au volant en état
d'ébriété en 2012
salik et pour être un bilan sierre
mais pour ça que moi et je pense que je
fasse ma part parce que je me dis faut
pas arrêter d'en parler
là je pense qu avaient été sensibilisés
ne sera peut-être pas encore assez et de
toute évidence très jeunes spectateurs
ont été touchés par son message ses
conséquences mais en voyant l'émotion de
la mère en voyant qu'ils se montrer
qu'on entre en plus conscience juste
avant l'émission comme semer montrer
qu'on va peut-être plus sensibles ni
russie avait des vraies témoignage de
madame dame à l'abattage a aussi réalisé
commence nos parents peuvent se sentir
avec ceux appointés par an on veut
trouver un taxi au pg on peut le payer
le taxi je m'amuse je me paye 20 pièces
que perdre un ami
simplement ça si il faut le savoir les
chronos bien que l'impact de ce genre
d'initiative soit difficile à mesurer il
semble clair que tous les efforts
nécessaires à l'organisation depuis cinq
ans d'un événement à aussi grande et
plus n'ont pas été fait en vain un peu à
mal balle ou après les bals de
finissants pour le territoire de la mrc
des maskoutains
on a pas d'accidents avec blessés graves
ou de collisions mortelles dont conduit
peut-être que le message passe mal
un succès donc quand même attiré
l'attention d'autres corps policiers des
membres du service de police de montréal
étaient présents pour observer et
peut-être même inspiré de l'initiative
de feytiat sain et philippe marcou radio
canada satya sai